[Musique]
bonjour tu sais ça libère bonjour mon
idole temps bonjour aux auditeurs de
matinée vous êtes c'est le maire du mort
de verre merci d'être avec nous à propos
de ce qui alimente actuellement les
discussions c'est des mairies des
municipalités cette disparition de la
taxe d'habitation lui c'est ça libère
comme vos collègues des autres communes
de martinique de france vous redoutez
cette décision gouvernementale pour metz
durant la campagne présidentielle
emmanuel macron évidemment mais je crois
que pour bien comprendre
nos difficultés il faut resituer cette
perte fiscale cette perte de recettes
fiscales dans un contexte évidemment le
contexte est déjà un contexte où nous
avons une dotation globale de
fonctionnement qui diminue le contexte
c'est aussi l'obligation que nous avons
pour tous nos établissements publics les
rp les femmes établissements recevant du
public de nous mettre aux normes donc
d'avoir de nouvelles dépasse le contexte
c'est aussi le fait que nous devons
jouer dans nos communes le rôle
d'amortisseur social en essayant de roy
socialiser un petit peu tous ces jeunes
qui sont laissées à l'abandon qui saura
vous demande de faire toujours de plus
en plus avant qu'on vous donne de moins
en moins absolument c'est absolument
aujourd'hui on en redemande encore deux
paires de pattes hier vous l'avez me dis
aussi ou trois ans puisqu'en fait
diminution a lieu jusqu'à 2020 par tiers
en doublement de le perdre encore une
recette dans un contexte déjà de
restrictions budgétaires dans un
contexte de perte de cette peluche et ça
libère le président de la république
sont son premier ministre ont dit qu'ils
allaient compenser dès la première année
vous vous ne perdrez rien pas même un
euro c'est ce qu'ils disent oui c'est ce
qu'on nous annonce mais vous savez
souvent dans le coup nous avons
l'habitude ou si je veux bien faire
confiance au président et je lui fais
confiance surtout il l'a annoncé lui
même mais vous savez avec quels délais
dans quel délai est ce qu'il va le faire
tout de suite
par quel type de recettes rien ne nous
est annoncé sous ça pour l'instant on
oublie simplement que nous allons perdre
partir cette taxe est pour nous dans une
petite commune comme celle du maule vers
moins de 2000 habitants valérie ses
habitants c'est vrai c'est quoi pour
cette commune du bourg de festi sens et
4000 euros
disons que nous allons peine cinquante
mille euros par an jusqu'à 2020
c'est comme me le faut voir ce que ça
repose en paix ces cinq autres contrats
disons 50 contrats de jeunes
si on estime que le contrat du jeune d'à
peu près 1000 euros avec toutes les
charges
la formation labit max et la c5 faut
savoir c'est 50 personnes ça représente
1,5 en termes de salaire mensuel cette
compensation de l'impôt non c'est une
compensation de l'état promise par par
emmanuel macron par son premier ministre
vous n'avez pas peur que ça devienne
dégressif au fur et à mesure et qui
brusquement belle à disparaître les
autres à mai
toutes les façons ou gmail j'imagine que
c'est vers cette orientation que nous
irons puisque dans le contexte
d'endettement de la fois tout ce qui est
bon à poil en particulier sur les petit
je le dis franchement tout ce qui est
beau à point et on le prendra une fait
pas confiance aux listes a finalement
comment voulez vous faire confiance vous
dû à l'état lorsque l'état vous le monde
le faire des choses d'état vous met à
genoux il vous donne pas de moyens pour
fonctionner avec leurs révisions des
vous étiez devant 6000 maire il n'est
pas les moyens de faire comprendre à
l'état qu'il se trompe mais oui mais
malheureusement vous savez bien que la
société tout simplement la chance d'être
plutôt pas du tout ceci vous je ne sais
pas que ce viol temps si vous avez déjà
assisté une fois à l'association des
maires la réunion de l'association des
maires qui se passe au congrès des
maires en france
si vous avez déjà si c'était une fois
quelques fois les opposantes au loup de
mon père de venir les les mêmes les
présidents certains ont décliné notre
invitation
tellement le chahut est important devant
les diminutions de recettes que nous
avons tort de tous par les études ont
été faites là dessus mais pourtant
depuis paris les décisions sont prises
alors lui c'est ça libère l'alternative
pas ce qu'ils font quand même l'évoquer
l'alternative se serait croix pour vous
dans votre cas bien précis d'humour
nevers la disparition de 150000 euros a
encore une fois je le dis l'alternative
serait une décision gouvernementale pour
augmenter notre dgf des 50 milliards sur
l'eau varie en fonction c'est la
première dotation globale de
fonctionnement serait la première
solution mais le problème vous savez
prévoir c'est gagné aujourd'hui ce que
les maires nous devons faire c'est
essayer de savoir dans quelle rubrique
dans quel comportement
nous allons essayer d'avoir une
diminution des charges de fonctionnement
pour compenser vous vous n'évoquez pas
la hausse des impôts c'est très
difficile nous pour thomas le vert s'ils
voient que nous avons des taux
d'imposition relativement barre pour la
taxe d'habitation taux moyen autour de
13 quand vous regardez vous pouvez le
le consulter quant aux niveaux au niveau
de la martinique c'est déjà bon autour
de 30% mais il faut une augmentation
d'impôts qu'ils soient en comparaison
avec le salaire moyen les revenus moyens
de la population de leur nez il ya des
leviers sur lesquels vous pouvez
actionner par exemple travailler sur
cette base fiscale les impôts il
faudrait s'attendre à des enquêteurs qui
viendront mesurer les surfaces compter
le nombre des tâches dans les maisons
pour ces ça ne nous gêne pas ça
ne nous gêne pas et là encore je peux
vous dire que s'agissant d'une commune
rurale vous savez bien que vous
connaissez l'état de l'aviculture
martinique loi vous connaissez les
difficultés des agriculteurs
nous avons une commune daric
d'agriculture et deux autres étaient les
vôtres et et vous connaissez les
retraites je vais pas vous faire le
schéma là dessus avec la diminution
encore annoncé qui est qui et les 70
sous 2% de la csg bon les retraités vont
encore souffrir les agricultures ils se
battent ils se débattent dans les
communes rurales pour survivre
bon ils n'ont pas de véritables
structures pour pouvoir écouler leur
production ils sont dans les difficultés
énormes pour ce qui concerne la la la la
création même de cette de cette richesse
parce que les conditions d'exploitation
sont 13 cadres je sais pas si vous
connaissez le monde le vert sur ce sont
des terrains pentus ou les joues vous
devez war doubler d'efforts ça n'est pas
mécanisables vous avez à faire on l'a
bien compris mais je vous reprends de
questions est ce qu'il faut c'est ce
qu'on pensait excusez moi que vous
continuez est ce que vous pensez
dans un tel est dans un état et à lequel
notre population se trouve qu'il faut
valoir jouer sur les taux puisque c'est
de ça qu'on va parler
le levier fiscal c'est bien augmenter
les taux pour avoir un peu plus loin
sept bris à les regarder sur le
continent bt déclaré des piscines que tu
es construit parce qu'il s'agira de
st-gall - oui nos mails ça ça c'est fait
nous avons un contrôle relativement
important ceci dit ceci dit je dois
reconnaître parce qu'il faut le dire
aussi
je dois reconnaître comment le vert au
niveau de ce qu'on appelle le pead aider
notre plan d'aménagement de
développement durable nous avons décidé
que le monde vert resterait comme nous
cependant il faut continuer à loger les
enfants qu'est ce qu'un outil qu'est ce
que vous provoquer ce que vous leur
proposez j'ai travaillé à bord pendant
38 ans est ce que vous pensez qu'un
jeune qui commence à travailler peut
s'acheter 500 voix 500 ou 1000 mètres
carrés de terres autour de 80 à 100
euros et construit une maison le plus
petit f3 ou f4 vous reviendra le sens de
130000 euros est ce que vous pensez
combien de jeunes aujourd'hui peuvent
construire en martinique les opérateurs
les opérateurs
quand nous connaissons enfin je ne peux
pas les citer vous les connaissez comme
moi même ozanam hlm etc bon ils font pas
ils font très peu dans notre commune le
programme de développement en
l'acquisition proposée de la vocation il
ya des choses à revoir les enfants alors
vous allez me dire pour ce véhicule et
si je suis le contrôle si vous voulez
c'est de ça que vous allez me réal et le
contrôle des maisons et que c'était
n'avons pas le site voici treize ans non
pas de gens qui construisent en
permanence mais des villas avec piscine
du moins taxés au taux maximum pour
faire entrer des recettes mais par
contre nous pouvons autoriser aux
enfants de construire autour de chez les
parents parce que là quelle solution
vous leur proposez alors également
peut-être la révision de cd de cette
base fiscale mais surtout pour vous il
s'agira tout simplement de de réduire
les dépenses moins d'investissements
dont la réduction des dépenses
ça dégage beaucoup un petit peu plus des
pagnes déjà la première chose et nous
nous sommes obligés de continuer à
investir un minimum nous sommes une
commune rurale où vous avez le problème
c'est que 1 km2 ottoman le vert
nettement plus cher qu'un kilomètre de
route au lamentin pas exempt parce que
vous savez que vous avez des bouts de
soutènement vous êtes cap etc
nous avons l'obligation de continuer non
seulement investir mais aussi à
entretenir entretenir les erp et là
j'entends les établissements recevant du
public que nous avons dans nos communes
riches cantine etc
il faut continuer à le faire chaque fois
que vous intervenez ou un établissement
vous devez respecter les nouvelles
normes et les nouvelles normes ces
dépenses supplémentaires
nous sommes obligés de le faire donc
lorsque nous faisons des demandes auprès
de l'état que ce soit par
l'intermédiaire de la dotation
d'équipement des territoires eu la
fameuse de théo ou le foie exceptionnel
d'investissement le ferry on ne rechigne
jamais à 100% donc
ils ont dégagé une marge
d'autofinancement caf
alors pour pouvoir faire ses invités ça
libère oui vous allez devoir réduire
dans les effectifs ou bien demander à
vos équipes d'être beaucoup plus
compétitive beaucoup plus productive
forcément alors que j'aurais dû faire du
social ont embauché à tire-larigot sans
forcément heureux il avait les
compétences des uns des autres
oui mais qu'est ce que vous voulez
aujourd'hui je ne dis pas que nous
allons pouvoir par exemple pérenniser
nous avons 36 emplois par exemple ans et
oui je vais pas dire que nous allons les
pérenniser
mais nous allons jongler pour le rhdp m
permettre à ces gens bons de devenir
titulaire
quand c'est possible parce qu'il ya des
règles il ya des règles qui régissent la
titularisation de ces individus mais je
crois que de notre côté avec
l'informatisation avec la digitalisation
avec la numérisation
nous étions aussi de faire un certain
nombre d'efforts en termes de
rentabilité de productivité employés
moins bonnes mais de façon beaucoup plus
efficace très rapidement lui c'est ça
libère puisque noie sa peine quelques
secondes
être mère aujourd'hui c'est fun c'est
sexy je peux vous dire qu'à toi mais
aujourd'hui c'est il faut d'abord un
équilibriste et puis il faut tous les
jours réfléchir se projeter pour se dire
comment demain on essaiera d'équilibré
commandes mais on essaie de satisfaire
les besoins de notre population
comment le maire nous essayons de
d'attirer un petit peu de conserver
puisque un petit peu de calme de notre
commune tout en ayant une satisfaction
maximum de deux de nos administrés c'est
ça le problème
c'est ça c'est aujourd'hui c'est assure
combat que nous sommes tous les joueurs
appelés quoi aller je peux vous dire que
ce n'est pas facile plus cher ça libère
mers du monde les remercie d'avoir tu ce
matin 900 cas dit merci beaucoup
monsieur violent et à bientôt
[Musique]
les créateurs